M1: It's been another week and it's time for
a covid weekly update, Tuesday seemed to be a
good day for these because it allows sort of the
weekend data to be smoothed out. Sometimes on the
weekends. There's these dumps of data, sometimes
on the weekends, data and reporting slow down
on vaccines or cases or whatever. So looking at
it, Tuesday, Wednesday seems to make sense. And
we're going to look again at cases to begin with.
F3: But increasingly, you know, it's more and more
people get vaccinated and getting the virus
for the vaccinated means something much less
serious than it used to. For unvaccinated people,
cases may become less an important indicator than
hospitalizations and of course, deaths, as are
more important measures. But let's start where
we always do with cases. Cases in the United
States peaked on January 11th. At the incredible
and nearly unbelievable number of 250, 5000 cases
per day since that peak cases have declined about
78 percent to 55000 cases per day. Now, 55000
cases per day, still outrageous. And when we got
up to 55000 cases per day, we were completely
horrified and rightly so. Many never imagined
we'd ever get to fifty five thousand cases a day.
Remember, some people told us 15 cases will soon
be zero. But right now, 55000 cases a day means
we're down 78 percent in about two months. So
that's the right direction. If we saw another
78 percent decline over the next two months,
we'd be at about 12000 cases in mid-May. Now,
it's unclear whether that's going to happen.
The decline has already slowed down, but at the
same time, if vaccination continues to accelerate,
maybe the decline will accelerate as well. We
just don't know right now in terms of people
going into the hospital each day with the virus.
We peaked right around January 9th when 16000
people were being hospitalized each day with the
virus in the United States. We are now at forty
five hundred people being hospitalized each day
with the virus. That's a decline of 73 percent.
And then in terms of the total number of people
in the hospital with covid right now, that peak
was also on January 10th when we had one hundred
and twenty four thousand people in the hospital.
That number is down 75 percent to 30000 people
remaining in the hospital with covid in the United
States. And then deaths, deaths peaked around the
end of January at more than a nine elevens worth
of deaths every day. We were seeing about 3400
deaths a day at the end of January. Deaths are
now down to an average of 12, 82, which is still
horrifying, but it's a decline of 63 percent. It's
tough to be happy about twelve hundred
eighty two people dying a day of this virus.
And yet we recognize that being down 63 percent to
12 82 is better than a continued spike to 12 82 in
the sense that the direction we're going in is the
right one. And remember that deaths trail cases
by a few weeks. They're a lagging indicator.
So we expect that deaths would continue down
similar to cases. But again, at a certain point,
as more people get vaccinated and people start
doing more things, you may see cases level out
because people will be transmitting the virus.
But because so many people will be vaccinated,
they're not going to be seriously ill. That
may happen. We're not there yet, but we may be
going in that direction now. Lastly, vaccination,
vaccination. We want to see going up of most of
these indicators, indicators we want to see go
down vaccinations you want to see go up. And we
are now averaging two point four million vaccine
doses injected per day over the last week. That
is a number that continues to go up. Last week we
were at two point one million a day. Now we're at
two point four million a day. And we have roughly
thirty eight million fully vaccinated Americans
and another 32 million partially vaccinated.
That means about 70 million Americans are fully
or partially vaccinated. These are increasingly
good numbers to see. Now, one last thing. These
are all U.S. numbers, what is happening globally
with the virus is the virus growing or diminishing
globally? And the answer is it sort of depends.
There are parts of the world seeing spikes. Look
at Brazil. Brazil has been one of the worst places
in the world for covid handling. Thanks to both
scenario, it actually is now peaking. Brazil is
now at the highest of its four or five peaks, with
more active cases today than at any point during
the pandemic in Brazil. There are some European
countries starting to spike. Vaccine rollout has
not been great in many parts of Europe and indeed
globally. Overall cases are going up while they
are down almost 80 percent. In the U.S., cases are
going up globally. Cases globally bottomed out at
around three hundred and sixty thousand today, not
long ago, a few weeks ago. They are now back up to
four hundred and thirty thousand global cases
a day. Fortunately, deaths continue to decline,
partially because many countries are getting
better at treating people who get seriously ill,
partially because the world is starting to
vaccinate the most at risk individuals. But deaths
peaked around fourteen thousand a day in early
February. There are now 8500 people a day globally
dying of coronavirus. So the takeaways are there's
a ton of work to be done. Numbers are improving
in countries that have done more vaccination,
but there are still parts of the world seeing
more cases. There are still parts of the world
that aren't likely to get any significant number
of vaccines for a long time. All we can do is
go by the guidelines that our respective health
authorities are giving us in the U.S. It's the
CDC, CDC urging caution, but opening up some safe
activities for vaccinated people. We will give
it another week and then see where things are.